wochenlang berichten wir von der
rettungsaktion der afghanen nach
deutschland und jetzt diese schreckliche
tat hier direkt bei uns vor der haustür
bist du überrascht na ja an dieser tat
erleben wir dass das worüber wir in
afghanistan gerade reden die ich hier
auch in deutschland längst realität
geworden ist das was dort passiert ist
ist eine bluttat ist ein mordversuch auf
grundlage der scharia ein mann der nicht
damit einverstanden ist dass frauen
arbeiten insofern muss man sich
natürlich fragen ob diese
evakuierungsaktionen die wir in den
letzten tagen gesehen haben 5000
menschen aus afghanistan auszufliegen
bei denen jetzt noch weitere
vorbestrafte straftäter dabei waren die
aus deutschland schon mal abgeschoben
worden sind ob die vor dem hintergrund
solcher ereignisse nicht ja besonders
dramatisch erscheint daher ist es kein
einzelfall julian vor ein paar tagen
waren es zwei aufgaben die ihre
schwester grausam ermordet hat man dann
in einem koffer durch halb deutschland
geschleppt haben dann wir haben es
vorhin dem opener gesagt gibt es unter
denen die wir aus afghanistan gerettet
haben auch viele kriminelle
vergewaltiger dabei wie gehen wir jetzt
mit dieser situation um um mich jetzt
ins gegenteil zu verfallen erst retten
wir alle und jetzt plötzlich erhalten
wir alle afghanen für kriminelle die
antwort ist ganz leicht um was ordnung
ordnung ordnung wir haben es ja im
ordner hier eben gesagt faszinierende
und gleichzeitig bittere zahlen
deutschland hat aus afghanistan mehr
menschen rausgeholt von denen wir nicht
mal wissen wer sie sind über 200
menschen ohne papiere als ortskräfte
ortskräfte ungefähr 160 170 noch mal wir
haben mehr menschen aus afghanistan gut
von denen wir nicht wissen wer sie sind
als die die wir eigentlich retten
wollten hinzu kommt eine signifikant
hohe zahl von straftätern die wir
rausgeholt haben und daran sieht man
dass nach 2015 zum zweiten mal das fehlt
was es für migration zwingend braucht
ein geordnetes verfahren jetzt kann man
sagen gut anders als 2015 haben wir
dieses mal ja nur 5000 geholt relativ
kleine zeit man kann aber auch umgekehrt
sagen wir schaffen es trotz der
erfahrung von 2015 nicht mal für 5000
menschen ein geordnetes verfahren zu
entwickeln das wäre ja eigentlich der
mindestanspruch gewesen dass man nach
den erfahrungen der vergangenheit weiß
wir brauchen weil immer mehr menschen
nach deutschland holen was vollkommen
legitim es wenn es zum beispiel um
ortskräfte geht ein geordnetes verfahren
sodass wir wissen wer kommt hier zu uns
das wussten wir nicht dass wissen wir
teilweise noch immer nicht und das
ergebnis ist dass ein mann der in
deutschland zu acht jahren gefängnis
verurteilt worden ist wegen schweren
sexuellen missbrauchs von kindern jetzt
wieder in deutschland ist der ist
abgeschoben worden und jetzt mit luft
halten mit luftwaffe und lufthansa
wieder nach deutschland gebracht worden
sitzt jetzt zwei im gefängnis kommt
dabei den 170 tagen raus und wandelt
dann frei auf unseren straßen ohne dass
wir noch abschieben können gleicher fall
bei einem vergewaltiger gleicher fall
bei einem mann der wegen schwerer
körperverletzung in deutschland
verurteilt worden und erst im februar
abgeschoben worden ist wenige monate
später sechs monate später ist er
glücklich zurück in deutschland hat noch
70 tage im gefängnis und dann spazierte
frei auf und lieber julian